[Aplausos]
estamos prontos para o tour já
todos os presentes nesta sala a 10 em
padecemos potencialmente de um problema
a resolução não é algo reservado aos que
estão presente é de toda a humanidade e
o vírus há sempre com o vírus o vírus
que o portador desta maleita chama-se
ignorância
vamos tentar
neste dia fazer vos convencer nos que é
possível ultrapassar este problema
eliminando o vídeo nós somos números
somos dados
eu sou o o 997 645 c3 também soou o novo
dos 523 5 e os 6 9 7
em alguns dias o sim 3 104 hoje estes
identificadores que materializam a nossa
existência estão carregados numa
infraestrutura global da informação que
a unidade chamamos de internet estão
naquilo que chama a nuvem
no entanto ao contrário daquilo que
seria espectável a nuvem não está nos
céus
é uma infraestrutura física composta por
uma vida e por equipamentos uma
infraestrutura física estava embaixo
d'água consubstanciado em cabos
submarinos que ligam todos os
continentes do mundo
basicamente a água em estado gasoso está
debaixo d'água
esta quantidade de informação que eu ia
quer jogada é incomensurável giga era ex
bytes de informação sobre é nossa vida
pessoal é nossa saúde
a nossa relação com o estatuto as
empresas e as nossas emoções os nossos
desejos estão todos carregados no banco
claro que a todos mal intencionados quer
entrar a partir dessas situações estados
querem controlar ou ter a partir dessa
circunstância para seus interesses
estratégicos empresas que querem ganhar
dinheiro de forma não esse tal ilícita
pessoas individualmente consideradas que
turma má fé é uma intenção que querem
prejudicar terceiros simples cobrir tudo
isso faz parte dos riscos associados
provavelmente já ouviram isto muitas
vezes não terá muita atenção alguns de
vós os que querem cá o nosso e vende ozu
devem provavelmente e ter ligado do
telemóvel interesse da rede wifi aqui do
museu é é traz gasta
ou fazerem isso estão a permitir que
quem gera esse recurso tem acesso à
informação dos voz equipamentos
admitindo que as pessoas que o fazem é
que fazem esse serviço tem estão bem
intencionados e não estou usar outras
ferramentas de acesso à informação mais
reservada
então poderemos talvez confiar ou não
outros não se registando essa redução
pode ser listado na venda é r traz 10 12
obrigado por compartilhar nossos dados
comigo essa renda minha está ligado no
meu telemóvel e novamente estão a deixar
estão a transpor para uma entidade que
não conhecem
para uns uma ir para uma existência de
silício não é essa em grande parte da
vossa identificação da vossa existência
é que os machos cuidadosos não se
registaram nenhuma regra nem noutra
mesmo assim tenha rede podem ter a vossa
resultados móveis ligado até o bulls fim
de pior é que o que eu quero dizer com
isto é que é muito fácil muito premiada
somos um existe uma grande produtividade
e nós ligamos nesta infraestrutura
muitas vezes de forma contínua e eu não
tenho vai falhar aberto eu não tenho
muitos mas eu tenho que ir ao hospital
eu tenho que tratar os meus impostos eu
tenho que escrever empresas ainda foi um
grande parte da informação que gera
minha vida e pronta que vai esse papel
desenho a sistemas de informação a tudo
à distância exata passa tudo novamente
para nuno claro que a ambição inicial
desta minha toca seria escutar uma
aplicação que já recebi aqui essa aula e
que de alguma forma nos trouxesse
evidências de que isto disse
corra o risco que ela portuguesa
considera a tentativa crime não é uma
contravenção não é uma infração gera é
crime
eu não queria ter a polícia judiciária
espera é fira a top mas posso ajudar
hipoteticamente a ideia do que é que
tudo iria acontecer numa situação dessas
é mesmo um telemóvel é possível fazer
alguma ação conduza a um maior
conhecimento de quem está aqui e do que
de que tipo de informação e informação
todos vós têm nos gols secretamente
esta é o facto de isso acontecer aos
hipoteticamente se acontecesse talvez me
permite dizer que é eventualmente
haveria aqui nessa sala alguém que
estava mal acabava em ordem dos 235
importante comentou a nossa sra
provavelmente a maioria equipe
taticamente poderia
a dar conhecimento que na segunda-feira
alguém nome joão terá uma reunião às 10
horas com ao chamado carlos
hipoteticamente obviamente e
provavelmente também ou hipoteticamente
não poderia dizer que alguém carro no
facebook fotos do aniversário do filho
que aconteceu na semana passada
tudo isto é poético é alguém até podemos
achar alguma piada parecem que são
coisas públicas relevantes no entanto
comportam sempre riscos não apenas
ficarmos com a nossa vida exposta e e
também posso dizer que não precisa
destas ferramentas por grande parte do
trabalho nós fazemos
usamos as redes sociais e carregamos
tudo e mais alguma coisa para tornar
público a nossa urgência vai dava faz
parte
ora acabamos por deixar uma pegada
digital muito significativa com um
conjunto de dados ficam à disposição dos
estágios a todos que têm a capacidade de
processamento dessa informação tudo
adiantou falar da inteligência
artificial é a quantidade de informação
e dados que existem não são parecidas
que permitirá ao ser humano uma um
tratamento individual é e em directo
temos que recorrer a outros sistemas
mais inteligentes com capacidade de auto
aprendizagem parcial mas agora vem
acabam por nos dividir em silos colocam
em saquinhos cada um com time e nós
fazemos parte do que não disse e
desvarios deus podem nos colocar na que
os consumidores que gostam mais do sul
podem colocados mas que os consumidores
gostam mais do brownie de chocolate
podem também nos colocar na que o saco
dos pretos ou dos brancos
'nossa do masculino e do feminino no
saco do assim-assim naqueles que têm
doenças oncológicas na que o uso em fim
iminente
ficamos com vários tanques e precisa ser
algo de marketing e podemos pensar
existe o menor dos meus problemas é
terminar gente voz site na internet
imediatamente não sugerem aqui um
produto que sabem a partir daí que eu
gosto é confortável mas também muito a
nossa opção de escolha de alternativas
nós tivemos nos últimos dois anos vários
eventos a nível global que de alguma
forma e de forma direta é se relacionam
com esta matéria
as norte americanas foram alvo de um
conjunto de pressões de dados de uma
empresa consultora que faz este
tratamento de informação que seria pouco
e permite criar vários preciso de
eleitores norte-americanos que foi
depois vendida é uma candidatura nos
estados unidos
neste caso esta candidatura com certeza
que outras candidaturas também compraram
de outras empresas tipo de informação
nos devemos ser ingênuos mas que
permitiu essa candidatura em concreto
obter sucesso e produzindo conteúdos
informacionais dirigidas a cada um
daqueles target daqui os segmentos do
mercado eleitoral sobre o mesmo tema mas
com conteúdos ligeiramente diferenciados
e dirigidos a cada um desses mercados
eleitorais o que significa que um
candidato sobre a mesma questão pode ter
várias posições desde encontro a empatia
com diferentes
deletron se isto não é manipulação
dificilmente o encontro outro tipo de
descrição existo
então é um potencial que não é apenas
questões de natureza comercial questões
de roubo de dinheiro também uma
preocupação um pouco mais eletrônico e
outro tipo de serviços online que
processam as mensagens ainda algo para
um patamar superior
algo que coloca em causa a ele é
essência fundamental da nossa vida em
sociedade o sistema com que gm a
sociedade ea democracia
depois de listar as opções que não
correspondem necessariamente aquelas que
deviam ser as mais justas mas aquelas
para as quais a realidade que nos foi
apresentada foi mutilada
de acordo com o poder daqueles que são
os mais fortes e isso deve nos fazer
refletir se queremos continuar é que
tenham acesso é toda a informação que
dispomos nos nosso suporte de dados é
começar por telemóvel porque é o mais
óbvio e evidente mas os mark waters
o nosso portátil o nosso computador do
caso para dizer com menos neste toda
esta é envolvência faz-nos então
perguntar estou disposto é que de trata
e nos meus dados sem o meu consentimento
e confins em legítimo tudo quero
arriscar o que o funcionamento da
sociedade infraestruturas críticas como
a rede elétrica também uma casa
emblemática que funciona com o sistema
está lá estão baseados na internet água
telecomunicações
os serviços dos operadores tocava de
pessoas todos os meses ao arriscar e se
estou disponível largas cara
a forma como o sistema democrático que
todo funcionário seja no processo
eleitoral seja no referendo são as
questões que nós todos devemos fazer
qual é a solução desligue arma
o flamengo então ele é e não dá não dá
estamos de tal forma embrenhados nesta
taya neste género que mesmo que o trato
da informação em forma em suporte físico
e vai ser transformado em digital
estamos muito condicionados nesta
dimensão e temos que viver com ela
da mesma forma que circulamos na rua e
sujeito a um atropelamento ou viajar
mais de avião e outros tendem a não
ficar lá em cima quando estava um
problema técnico
diremos risco
tomamos opções que nos fazem e atuar em
risco controlado e é dessa forma que
devemos lidar também neste município
espaço e na questão do tratamento da
nossa informação dos nossos dados
pessoais
o mundo já não se via no mundo físico
em um mundo virtual o mundo é só um em
um mundo digital gil e não há
alternativa é uma situação que nos podem
causar o álbum sai algo muito até
pública é tecnologia capaz de saber mais
sobre nós do que nós próprios consegue
ver para lá em da nossa paulo
e sendo assim o risco ainda ganha uma
dimensão superior mas o medo é para 200
o medo é uma reação é uma reação natural
mas nós não nos podemos resignar
precisamos de ter conhecimento
eliminar os vídeos da ignorância
espero ter dado mais alguma consciência
sobre esta matéria mas não fiquem por
aqui vão um site do centro nacional de
biossegurança façam o curso de som line
gratuito de cidadão sinta seguro para
ganharem mais competências para saber
como lidar com esses riscos
o medo pode ser uma reação é tsé um
requer coragem
não me parece que seja preciso integrar
é de tal um evidente que fizeram é muito
obrigado